prima volta sugli sci dai va bene siamo
subito da loro in centro e poi primi
indietro premi dietro guarda che si
stacca gli ship così e cade adesso diva
divarica le code degli sci allontanando
i talloni sì ma contemporaneamente se
non ho freni raschia la neve con
l'interno hai presente quando ti sparo
il burro la mattina sulla fetta
biscottata e con raschia come raschi col
coltello raschia posti shideye allontana
titoloni non ti sedere braccia avanti ma
va che i bambini di tre anni of all
occhi chiusi è monastero hachette che
non ti servono a niente butta da da
meleam e il peso verso valle verso ma
come dove lava ma questa è la valle
piega studi no non stare rigido goditi
questa curva goditela dai ma va bene ci
rinuncio dai stai tranquillo altre 20
elezioni magari impari a stare in piedi
su di sì comunque sono 340 euro per
un'ora di lezione vai a pagare dentro a
scuola grazie ciao